at Sunday February 2nd 2020 so it's time
for another monthly update video I'm
going to be talking about what is coming
up in February and what you might have
missed in January if you want to see
links to the things I'm referencing just
click the see below in the video you
know interface and you'll see a whole
bunch of links pop up I always like to
begin by highlighting three big things
and so big thing number one is that I'm
going to be co-hosting a radio show
either starting in late February or
early March on Riverwest radio with Dan
Hayes it's called wisdom for life we'll
talk more about that in the February
part second big thing is that the
philosophers in the midst of history
talk series a quarterly series kicks off
for year five with a lecture and
discussion that's focused on Epicurus
and the epicurean tradition big thing
number three is that my wife Andy and I
have both been asked to at the upcoming
stoic on Ex Toronto which we'll be
following right after stoic on so we're
already getting you know geared up for
for that sort of thing and we'll be
focusing on one of our standard talks
the the stoic heart which has to focus
on relationships and particularly
romantic relationships so that's kind of
a fun thing to be invited to so those
are the big things let's talk now about
what happened in January January was a
bit of a slow month in some respects
certainly as far as events go although
we did do something really really cool
which is we have now started the the
first of what's going to be 12 monthly
meetings for the year for the Mk II
that's Milwaukee Sofia the Society of
philosophers in America and so we'll
talk more about that in the February
section about how you can find us
somewhere to go but it
a local organization that is part of a
national organization focused on undoing
philosophy in public way so we had our
first meeting and that went quite well
quite happy about that I also gave my my
talk in the year five of the worlds of
speculative fiction series on Mary
Shelley you can see the link to that
video below I did some online events my
usual ask me anything session a few
impromptu things as well you know I got
a new mic which you're hearing right now
and I did a session just about that so
there's there been you know some
philosophy pop ups as well and you know
January is the beginning of the the new
semester for many of my classes so I've
been gearing up for those started
teaching my face-to-face class at
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
and my online class for them as well and
I just recently this last week opened my
class for the second chance Pell program
that's prisons students that is through
MATC and I'm gearing up for starting
Carthage College fairly soon so I've
been you know doing some behind the
scenes things on my business ethics
class for Carthage as well a lot of
writing and collaborative work that I've
been working on not all of which is you
know necessarily been posted yet but I'm
working with a very bright graduate
student on a interesting project having
to do with causation and Pro erase this
and what's in our power and what's not
in our power the aristotelian and stoic
traditions and doing some other writing
and editorial work we're gearing up to
start working on publishing another
collected essays volume for stoicism
today and you know I've been in in doing
a lot of you know back-and-forth
communication about setting up talks
here and there speaking engagements so
that is is what's been going on and some
client work
as usual as well video work I didn't get
as much done as I had wanted to in part
because I spent a lot of the video time
working specifically on core concept
videos for my upcoming classes so I shot
some videos on James Dickey and his
institutional theory of art some some
new videos on Iran that I have been
releasing recently a video on Ursula K
Le Guin's the ones who walk away from
home a loss and a video on Hana
rent I also created a video about
trolley memes and I'll probably follow
up with that this month because it was
quite a hit talking about some of the
interesting trolley memes that are out
there and of course there's the event
videos the ones discussing the
particular you know authors and things
that I've been working on I also did
some some podcasting and I did an
interview for another pun podcast the
rendering unconscious podcast link to
that is below you can find but I been
also releasing podcast episodes in
January on Rene Descartes and her
manatees the poem that we have by him
and the fragments that we have by him so
I've been putting a bit more time into
the Sadler's lectures podcast and that
is pretty much it for what went on in
January there's a lot of you know
downtime a lot of getting back to the
gym and working out and sort of you know
just consolidating for the year ahead
what's coming up in February it's gonna
be a pretty busy month there's a lot
going on so let's start with the events
first if you're here in the local area
and local area doesn't just mean
Milwaukee it could be driving down from
the Fox Cities it could be driving up
from Chicago it could also be driving
over from you know Madison and that area
if you want to actually we've had people
come to our events from as far as
Michigan
so Milwaukee Sofia is on the 4th at 6
p.m. at the Mitchell Street library
we're having our second meeting which is
focused on friendship and relationships
and we're going to be talking a little
bit about Cicero but you don't
necessarily have to have read Cicero to
his on friendship in order to make sense
of it we're gonna have a sort of open
discussion about all sorts of ins and
outs about relationships and what
philosophy can actually contribute to
helping us understand them better the
day after that Wednesday the 5th will
have the aforementioned philosophers in
the midst of history's session at 6 p.m.
at the Frank Weinberg library up in
Mequon got another local event that is
on Epicurus and the epicurean tradition
so I'm going to be talking about you
know the history of that Epicurus and
his followers fit into and how he also
left his mark his influence on history
as well then the next week and on the
12th at 5 p.m. I'll have my monthly
Hegel Q&A and discussion session so
anybody who wants to come in and video
conference and talk about Hegel can can
do so then on the 13th of the day after
that 7:00 p.m. at the Brookfield Public
Library we'll be having our next worlds
of speculative fiction series lecture
and discussion and this time is focused
on China Melville and the BA slog novels
which are you know quite washing
interesting should be a really fun
discussion to have on the 22nd at 12:00
noon Central time of course I'll be
having my monthly ask me anything
session so you can pop in and you know
get involved in the chat ask me
questions you want to leave your
questions early because
they always get more than I can ever
answer in any given period then later
that day at 2:00 p.m. on the 22nd we
have the philosophy chat for patreon
supporters and then we round out the the
month on the 29th with a video premiere
video premiere that I was supposed to
get done this month but wasn't able to
get to unfortunately that'll be at 12
noon and I'll be talking about how to
study Augustine of Hippo effectively I'm
also doing another workshop but it's
only available for Milwaukee Institute
of Art and Design faculty and that's
coming later in the month that's
specifically on incorporating videos and
lecture capture into your classes and
but that's one that I actually have done
for a lot of other venues so if you're
interested in that sort of thing that's
something that people book before to
come in and give talks about since I do
so much video work that's a good segue
into talking about the videos for the
month so I mentioned that I didn't get
the self directed studies Sadler's
advice video on augustine done I'm gonna
get that hammered out this month and you
know start continuing that series will
have a video premiere for that a little
online party core concept videos I've
got some more rant videos to release and
I've also got some videos on Leo Tolstoy
and I'm gonna be shooting some some new
videos on Peter Singer as well for my
online ethics classes so I'll be
releasing those two to you and what else
do I need to do I got to do some half
hour Haegele videos got to do some book
reviews and I'm probably gonna do
another Sadler responds video about the
topic of people giving unsolicited and
undesired advice because I'm fighting it
it's quite needed it's nice to have
those videos that I can just say see
this plonk
they can watch it or not watch it the
podcast I am in the middle of doing some
Anselm footage for for that taking
videos and converting them into podcast
episodes and I'm you know doing all the
pro slow Gian and I might go on and take
the videos that I created on freedom of
choice and do that or I might just jump
into another author the podcast you know
I'm thinking who else do I want to do
for this month I haven't I haven't quite
decided yet but I have lots and lots and
lots of voice files that I can convert
over it's just a matter of finding the
time to do so and you know I'm doing all
the other usual stuff this month you
know my classes will all be in full
swing in February I've got lots of you
know client connections and work and got
a lot of meetings going on with various
institutions that may want me to come in
and give a talk or book me for something
else
a lot of editorial work a lot of writing
work so that is gonna keep me busy and
you know I'm gonna try to stick with the
exercise schedule you know other than
getting ill from time to time I've been
more or less able to do that and so I'm
kind of gratified about that and that's
that's that's really about it I'm not
travelling anywhere fortunately this
month that I know about and you know the
classes are going pretty well and you
know it's cold outside but that's the
way it should be here in Milwaukee in
the winter so everything is more or less
on track that's it for me I hope that
you have a great month ahead and if
you're in the area you know consider
coming to some of these local events if
you do you know introduce yourself to me
and say that you know you've heard about
it on this video otherwise you can stay
tuned for videos of the events that we
we do have
coming up and I hope that everything
goes well for for you
you